Аріні - всього 2,5 роки. Вона багато грається і сміється,
проте в очі одразу впадає катетер на її маленькій руці.
Спочатку діагностувати захворювання не вдалося.
А вже за місяць почалося повномасштабне вторгнення
і її сім’я опинилася під постійними обстрілами в Миколаєві.
Ми спускалися, по-перше, в підвал, бо були постійні і ці "Смерчі", і "Гради".
Миколаїв кожен день обстрілювали. Потім ми вирішили евакуюватися
в Румунію, бо моя фірма почала вивозити жінок та дітей.
У Румунії дитині стало гірше.
Больовий синдром. Постійно по ночах у неї болів животик.
Вже в Румунії,  ми там зверталися по швидкій навіть декілька разів.
Нічого не виявляли.
Тоді сім’я повернулася в Україну і об’їздила різні лікарні Закарпаття,
поки Аріні не поставили страшний діагноз - рак.
Пухлина була розташована біля хребта, тому видалити її
було дуже складно. За лікування дівчинки взялися лікарі
спеціалізованого дитячого медичного центру у Львові.
У Миколаєві залишитись без медичного догляду в той час,
коли обстріли, це було дуже страшно і складно. І те, що ми повернулися
в Україну, а не залишилися там за кордоном, це зберегло життя.
Бо саме тут ми знайшли порятунок, і тут нас почали лікувати.
Саме ця лікарня від початку повномасштабного вторгнення
стала опорним центром та евакуаційним хабом для важкохворих
дітей з усієї України. Через постійні обстріли, зачинені радіологічні центри
та склади з медпостачанням, онкохворих сюди вивозили
цілими відділеннями, а логістику організував благодійний фонд "Таблеточки".
Ми там і Укрзалізницю залучали, і міністерство охорони здоров'я,
і першу леді, і депутатів, і якихось просто бізнесменів,
наших донорів, спонсорів, хто готовий був надати якийсь транспортний засіб,
бажано з охороною, для того, щоб цих дітей без затримки довезти до Львова.
І там їх приймали, там їх обстежували, госпіталізували,
нормалізували їхній стан, бо діти після перебування
в бомбосховищах, в різних умовах, вони там, хто гарячкував,
хто потребував переливання крові, хто потребував антибактеріальної терапії,
антивірусної терапії, тобто лікарям було багато роботи.
Так сюди потрапив і 4-річний Богданчик, якого батьки вивезли
з окупованого Мелітополя.
Коли вже зайшли ці рашисти в наш населений пункт,
вже все було відрізано. Тобто лікарів, вже не було нікого.
І в той час ми помітили, що у Богданчика… Він якось так почав
дивитися телевізор не так, як раніше. І ліве око почало…
Стало не таке, як праве. Воно почало просто, знаєте, ніби вилазити.
Саме яблучко вилазити. Ми пройшли обстеженням в Запоріжжі,
в нас знайшли велику пухлину. Нас скерували в Одесу,
в клініку Філатова. Там зробили операцію хлопчику  і аналіз показав,
що то рабдоміосаркома, дуже, ну, знаєте, дуже така.
- Злоякісна? - Дуже, так.
Тоді сина терміново повезли у Львів. У цьому медцентрі
Богданчик провів вже понад рік.
- Важко тобі було?  - Так. Мені поставили метелика.
- Оце називається, так?  - Так.  - Боліло?  - Боліло.
- А зараз трошки краще тебе почуваєш?  - Так.
Я такого ставлення, як місцевих лікарів до нас, до дітей,
я на них не кажу лікарі, я на них кажу боги. Вони дійсно, знаєте,
дуже нам допомагають. Без них вже б нічого не було.
Ми приїхали, пройшли лікування, дев'ять хімій, вилікувалися,
все було добре. Потім я не знаю, від чого, чи від стресу знову.
І знову знайшли пухлину. І от в травні Богданчика знову прооперували.
Лікарня працювала у посиленому режимі 24/7 і допомогла
сотням важкохворих діток. Потік був просто величезним,
тому частину з них відправляли лікуватися за кордон,
щоб на їхнє місце могла приїхати нова хвиля пацієнтів
з окупованих чи прифронтових територій.
Ми не могли справитися з такою кількістю дітей.
У нас іноді поступало по 100 дітей важкохворих за день.
Розумієте, так? Я думаю, і нью-йоркська лікарня не справилась би з таким.
То що ми зробили? Ми, по суті, скоординували величезну
міжнародну мережу дитячих лікарень онкологічних,
які приймали цих дітей. Це все було скоординовано,
всі вони мали переклад своїх виписок, була координація
між українськими лікарями та іноземними,
і це все було безкоштовно для тих пацієнтів.
Допомогла у цьому американська лікарня St. Jude Children's Research Hospital,
яка розгорнула мережу розподілу українських дітей серед
європейських і північноамериканських клінік. У цій ініціативі
взяли участь 19 країн: Польща, Німеччина, Італія, Нідерланди,
США, Канада та багато інших. Таким чином вдалося евакуювати
понад півтори тисячі важкохворих пацієнтів разом із сім’ями.
Останній номер в реєстрі, який я бачив, це 1506.
Це неймовірна кількість, це більше, ніж за рік нових випадків
виникає в Україні. У цьому проєкті ми не просто дітей вивозили,
а і їхніх членів сімей. І тому загальна кількість людей,
яким ми допомогли, ми не вивозили їх якимись нещасними автобусами,
ми вивозили медичним транспортом, в супроводі іноді вертольоти,
іноді медичний військовий потяг натівський приїжджав до Шегинів.
Це понад 3 тисячі їхніх членів сімей також.
Зараз кількість дітей, яких евакуйовують за кордон,
зменшилася - максимум 5-7 на тиждень. Та лікарня все одно заповнена.
Пацієнтів насправді дуже збільшилось. Пацієнти, крім того,
що вони з усієї України, але й загалом їх збільшилося.
В нас, наприклад, зараз це близько 25 пацієнтів,
і двоє з них дорослі хлопці, які можуть отримувати лікування
в амбулаторному режимі. Хоча колись ми такого ніколи не робили.
Але зараз ми мусимо переходити на такий режим, бо всім треба
отримувати лікування. Ми підлаштовуємося під кожну ситуацію окремо.
Комусь капаємо тільки вдень хімію, на ніч відпускаємо додому,
а на другий день вони приходять, і далі ми продовжуємо інфузії.
Тому що всі палати зайняті. Немає вільного ліжка.
Наш потік пацієнтів зріс вдвічі. Через те, що крім зовнішньої міграції,
є ще внутрішня міграція. Відповідно кількість важкохворих дітей,
яких ми лікуємо, зросла вдвічі. Кількість нашого штату також серйозна,
щоб це все утримати. І ліки всі ми отримуємо і від держави нашої,
і від наших закордонних партнерів, і від всяких міжнародних проєктів.
Тобто в нас є кілька джерел на всякий випадок: якщо одне з джерел
припиниться, то його підстрахує друге.
Та з фандрейзингом для онкохворих діток в Україні стало складніше,
кажуть у фонді "Таблеточки".
Бо в Україні зараз більшість наших традиційних донорів
або не платоспроможні, або вони зараз перемкнулися
на фінансування інших потреб, таких як безпека, армія і так далі.
І, звісно, дитяча онкологія, як така хронічна проблема,
вона відходить на другий план. Але вона для нас не відходить
на другий план, бо це наша місія - займатися цим питанням.
Дитячий рак нікуди не зник, війна його не скасувала,
війна не поставила його на паузу.
Тому тепер доводиться шукати інші джерела допомоги
- переважно іноземні, щоб продовжити рятувати маленьких пацієнтів.